[Music]
in sticky situations news submitted by
poor homie curry a music teacher is
suspected of contamination Wow having
flutes with Siemens you know I know this
oh my god does that's the same school
that Vince teaches that one yeah Vince
know so [ __ ] he had the Yannick
canceled they canceled his b-boy closet
cause he just like kids I like lower and
schools that you know it's a dancin
artists [ __ ] and then his whole classes
were canceled for a week it's because of
this [ __ ] teacher because there was
semen on these like handmade hoops that
he would give to these kids wait
handmade flutes like he would carve out
a flute and then come on it yeah yeah so
he's like I made this for you and they
found [ __ ] all over it like it was just
blatant crust on there you know how they
found it because that's the one thing I
can't find I don't know he doesn't know
either cuz he just got the email and he
just he was just talking to the
counselor and how many flutes all of
them this smells like bleach like how
how did people find out like was there a
glaze of come on the [ __ ] lip part
that's the thing we don't know like how
did they find out you know the guy
didn't eat Krispy Kreme doughnuts and
then make the flute oh they're like the
kids mom like come up to it and then she
played the flute and then she goes wait
a second wait a second honey honey what
does it taste like you kids don't know
alright no I don't think they know yeah
so how did they find out the moms really
planned out I just got Jackie off on
flus maybe the [ __ ] sick maybe they
ran out of adhesive and then he's like
oh it's like what uh [ __ ] eighty
people use rice instead of glue yeah
yeah they do yep interesting
my mom would do that said of a glue
stick you just care of I say just the
same you know what boggles my mind is
what type of pleasure does he get out of
this is it sexual or is it revengeful
cuz I would understand if there was a
fecal matter on the flute because he's
sticking it up his ass and what part of
the flute had to come on the finger part
on the butt tip is it on the be sharp
button
looks like the eggplant is it on a high
e make sure the paint has come in it too
well the kids decorate their own float
flutes that why that one has like 12
watermelon I I would wash that flute and
wonder what the ethnicity of that kid is
so if this flute smelled funny would you
put your lips on it no I would not I
would this is part of a program called
flutes across the world and so this
program goes to many schools all over
the place like okay across the country
in what I just paid this guy I gotta
come on every flute if he wants the
whole world to taste his cup in he's
like no pretty funny that's gross he's
like Oprah do you get one it's just like
how my [ __ ] comes out like a shotgun -
just a lot of effort for something so
[ __ ] stupid yeah so the flutes across
the world is a non-profit music program
that partners up with school districts
all over like or the OSI and LA and as
well as the Philharmonic Society of
Orange County and so apparently like we
don't know how they discovered this but
there were letters sent to a lot of
students in different schools that were
that did participate in this program
saying like hey if you have one of these
booths and by the way this all happened
like the time period that they're giving
is from last year's school yourself Mike
guy 16 oh and so they're telling parents
like hey if your kid participated in
this and if you still have a flute can
you please put it in a paper bag not
plastic cause it could damage the
evidence put it into a quick quest paper
bag and then turn it into law
enforcement and so they're gonna easily
find this guy
ya know yeah I know that they know who
did it and it's just one guys at
multiple it seems like it's one guy and
he's been obviously my everybody just
come though for sure it seems like that
yeah it's a whole [ __ ] [ __ ] flute
operation there's fourth and fifth
graders that work oh that's
[ __ ] I really do have to figure out who
the [ __ ] was the one that found out that
there
come on this thing because that [ __ ]
dries up so definitely somebody tasted
it that also means people aren't washing
their flutes before they play it which
they probably should I don't know you're
supposed to wash flutes I wouldn't have
as a kid I don't go [ __ ] I'm just trying
to play they're nasty when I played
saxophone I always had this how are you
nasty probably like 9 or 10 I'm pretty
old enough I don't always spray the
spray they told me to spray on the reed
first before I played it well that's
about the same age these kids are like
10 but that already doesn't look like a
professional it just looks like
something you just blow in yeah we
should still clean it up don't you I
wouldn't know
that's so interesting this is coming for
the men who literally puts up [ __ ]
with his hands right but I'm not putting
my mouth in my mouth it's clean he
[ __ ] practices the one minute roll
what one minute rules something falls on
before you still eat it unless I see a
guy jacking off on it spray the floor
first and then piranhas but that rule
suppose beat it sometimes it takes time
12 day rule I'll get you later I did
miss something it wasn't 2015-2016 it
was at 2016-2017 school year so yeah the
way he's coming on a lot of things yeah
this guy's at home he's carving these
flutes and then he's like sorry I can't
go to dinner
I got work to do and this is his passion
and he's just carving out empty food so
he could come on all of them to give to
children cuz he has to be very like
thought-out about it yeah yes laid out
in a row he has to not jack off for a
whole week
yup and then we're just gonna save it he
has to hold it at the end and then let's
pray I'm gonna go his process no you
don't that's disgusting I think the most
efficient way is to come at a cup brush
even application all vary across oh
maybe you're just doing that I mean you
put it in the [ __ ] uh you know the
bakery thing
shout out another buddy no you have a
bakery that paper the one that you could
draw people's names out and then no but
come becomes liquidy after a while
though
oh yeah does much would heat how that's
so crazy but they haven't really said
how many of these flutes did contain
semen especially now that they're trying
to collect but all we know they could
have just been one he came into a spray
bottle that's diluted with water and
that's his signature cuz you know how
artists I sign a name at the end of the
canvas he just better than DNA yeah Tom
Schrader Shane makes sense there's a
real Thomas traitor I think it's
probably a lot of come on that for you
to recognize that like yeah that's what
I need to know it had to be a mother
that put her mouth on it that's just
Krispy Kremes that's what I'm saying
this smells like Cobb yep
yeah he's like your nose [ __ ] hurts
[ __ ] you almost made a note
this is crazy is that an offense where
you as a parent would go find this guy
oh look his [ __ ] ass yes yes I beat
the living [ __ ] parents are saying that
the school district they should be
testing all these kids that got four
STDs oh hey should I hope he doesn't
have an STD but I feel like as a parent
I would be mortified but as a comedian
I'm laughing yeah how fresh is the car
because the [ __ ] is really fresh then
it's pungent but if it's but if it's
like taking and like it's all like dried
up just looks like dried glue yeah so
because of that it just blows my mind
house like that that can't even happen
I'm pretty sure like you don't open
school nights burial is not gonna let me
come wait what let me come to the things
I did not yes you did you mean like a
PTA or whatever you can have all the
parents come and do an open house or
something
y'all parents come over and they kind of
just like do the the thing thing where
they you know hey these are like yeah
you're gonna embarrass your kid or well
I'm almost me she's I don't let me come
though cuz I'm just gonna laugh at
everybody and all these kids have these
stupid-ass project something fun other
than [ __ ] you can't even be human I
can't be laughing I'll try but then the
laughter will always come out yeah it's
hard yeah it's really difficult what
were you guys what are you gonna be
letting him go to school in it yeah of
course I would love to go to Mexico
night you should part if you'd alive
this is what I mean
well grandma comes along she live wrong
she's not coming oh damn no no no
grandparents are you gonna like pass the
torch though you do the same things your
mom did to take that you can do it no
child needs to go through the things
that I went through no he has an awesome
mom so that [ __ ] happened yeah next
time you want to visit him you piece of
[ __ ] no I like the baby mm-hmm just not
the mother yeah I get it
oh yeah I was gonna say that
did your parents go to PTA things my mom
worked at the school people okay I
always wanted my mom to go to my parents
were never that I was always the kid
without parents me too
my mom was required to go to the school
like three times a week cuz I was got so
much trouble
so no open house is different than like
I know but my mom and my teacher already
had a relationship so they don't ever
have to go to the back-to-school night
cuz I already have each other on like
speed that type shape those would be a
fun night it was so interesting too I
wish maybe schools are different but if
I think if a kid is constantly getting
into fights they should look more into
it than just blaming the kid do you know
cuz yeah cuz I always had to go to the
principal office I was always in the
[ __ ] office sitting on that [ __ ]
same chair waiting to talk to the
[ __ ] vice principal or the principal
and they just never looked into it he
started like a troublemaker but I wasn't
a troublemaker I was a kid that got
bullied a lot so I get bullied and then
I would [ __ ] smash that kid's face
with the rock and then I'm the violent
one yeah they don't try to understand
this situation they don't understand
that if I'm getting bullied by four or
five kids of course I'm gonna defend
myself you know like that's what's gonna
happen
but then they're all the victims and
then also the [ __ ] happen that I
[ __ ] static in the face move to a
different school it's probably cuz they
don't know who the aggressor is or who's
right or who's wrong it's just a bunch
of kids yeah he's probably six three at
like nine I mean I was definitely bigger
that's why they you have to get like a
few kids to do stuff to you I remember I
got in trouble my dad had to stay like
the whole day with me the whole class he
was just sitting next to me this was
like fourth or fifth grade yeah the
whole entire day and then the teacher
thought like it was so embarrassing for
me or it was punishment but I was
actually enjoying it because I got to
spend quality time with my dad I had the
same thing in first grade I know how the
deaths are hell alone yeah so my dad
sitting next to me his [ __ ] knees
were like this and his the desk was like
right here you just sitting there
watching me like the whole time yeah my
dad had to come to school that means I
was [ __ ] like at home that means I got
my ass beat I specifically remember this
like blue little office Shefford kids
I walked he he had to come after school
to pick me up he closes the door the
room the house is dark he
grabs that Roller [ __ ] and he [ __ ]
Chuck's it at the back of my head nearly
knocked me the [ __ ] that makes sense now
yeah and that worse instead I had a
stutter hello guys I hope you guys enjoy
the video please remember to give us a
big thumbs up and a like like like and
also when you guys sign on YouTube make
sure just kidding news are the first
thing you watch every single day because
we post videos every day ok for more
videos